[موسيقى]
حشود كبيرة
واحدة من أكثر الطائرات خضرة
وواحدة من أكبر الطائرات ذات البدن
العريض التي تم إنتاجها على الإطلاق ، إنه لأمر رائع أن
نرى عددًا قياسيًا من الطائرات
معروضة ، فليس من المستغرب أن الكثير من
المتحمسين لمستقبل الطيران
هنا في معرض دبي الجوي  من
التكنولوجيا الناشئة والابتكار إلى
طائرة البوينغ ثلاثية 7x اللافتة للنظر التي
نراها هنا جميعًا ، لكن الكلمة الطنانة هذا
العام
تدور حول الاستدامة على سبيل المثال أعلنت لوفتهانزا أنها
سددت قرضها الأخير المتعلق بالوباء إلى
الحكومة الألمانية ،
والآن أصبح الحد من الانبعاثات هو
العدد الأول لدينا الآن 175 طائرة قيد
الطلب حتى نهاية العقد
لأن الطائرات الجديدة هي أسرع
طريقة لتقليل انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون.
قبل عامين ،
فكيف فعلوا ذلك أكثر من استخدام
وقود طيران مستدام وآمن وتحسين
خطة الطيران للطرق الفعالة
مع  المزيد من النزول المباشر في الهبوط ،
أود أن أعرض وجهة نظر مفادها أنه في غضون 10 سنوات
في عرض ممرضة مثل هذا ، سيظهر
الفائزون والخاسرون سيكون الفائزون هم
الذين حققوا أكبر قدر من
استدامة الطيران التجاري بمعدل 7 أضعاف  هي
طائرة بوينج جامبو جديدة ، إنها
أكبر
طائرة بوينج ذات جسم عريض
بمحركين ، وهذا هو أول
عرض جوي كبير حضرته هذه الطائرة ، وقد
تأخر عرضه في
أول رحلة جوية قبل شهور فقط
من تضرر الصناعة.
الوباء والطلب على الطائرات ذات الأجسام الكبيرة الذي
انخفض في الواقع هذه الأيام أكبر
ليس بالضرورة أفضل ، الاتجاه المربح
الآن هو الطائرات الأصغر ذات الكفاءة في استهلاك الوقود
بعد الوباء ، لم تستطع الكثير من الطائرات
الطيران بسبب نقص الطلب
على طراز إيرباص A321 الجديد لخيار المحرك
هي طائرة ذات ممر واحد ،
مما يعني أن نطاقها المتزايد يعني أنها تستطيع القيام
برحلات أطول مع عدد أقل من الركاب بتكاليف أرخص.
اشترى مالكو شركات طيران فرونتير وويز
المئات من هذه الطائرات ،
لذا فإن رؤية 250 طلبًا للعب هو
تعزيز للثقة في الصناعة ، حيث
تمكنت الصناعة من حل مشكلتها الأولى من خلال
العودة إلى الجو
الآن ، وهي تركز الآن على حل
مشكلتها الثانية من خلال البقاء.  مربحة
وفي نفس الوقت تحمي كوكب
kim kileta cnn dubai
[موسيقى]
لك